[Music]
greg's in portland oregon hi greg
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave well i'm happy to be here i
wish i was here under better
circumstances and
giving them my debt free speech but uh
not quite there yet
how can we help
well um yeah so i actually live in a
little town outside of portland here in
oregon on the north coast and uh i
married my wife she's she's the sweetest
woman you ever met uh you know about six
years ago
and uh i lost my job about three months
or so before she moved to the us from
out of state or out of country
um i started my business with the last
350 dollars in the bank account and we
were dirt poor for a while i'll tell you
i'm i'm 26 now i've been doing it for
about five and a half years
and uh it's grown a lot this last year
i've done about 26 growth i'm just now
starting to get a good wage from it
my wife's a teacher at the local school
district and she said you know she's
always looking for jobs and she saw an
i.t job there
which is basically what i do now but
it's entry level it's a little bit of a
pay cut but it comes with the benefits
and the security of it
all and that's what she wants is the
security and she's kind of given me an
alternative of you know she doesn't want
to have to deal with the business
anymore the you know up and down of it
and uh said you know
remember i might not be here tomorrow
i just need some fatherly advice here
your wife says she's going to leave if
you don't take a job that is a pay cut
she said she might and it's one of those
where i just don't know you know either
call her bluff or she's she's flush you
know
this has nothing to do with this job man
there's there's bigger things going on
your relationship here man
what about your what about your world
makes her feel not safe
why would she even need to make this
statement
well you know i guess i think you no i
don't guess you know you know don't
guess you know why doesn't she feel safe
why would she say something like that
you know some months i'm
way above what i would be making there
like three four times and then some
months i'm
just under what i'd be making there yeah
but you're talking about dollars and
cents who are you are you hard to be
around in the low months
no no i don't drink you know i don't do
drugs i'm a pretty e-going person you
know i
if i'm low then you know i do everything
i can to change it uh i consider it you
know to some extent reflection on myself
and i do everything to better the
situation you know
uh i don't like to be mopey if anything
i like to just go to work and double
down even more and uh you know triple
down on things
did i hear you say before you were
married she was an immigrant that she
came from another country
she did yeah she moved to the us here
china
china
and so she is an american chinese or
she's chinese
she's chinese and nationality and
in an upbringing yes her family is the
best people in the world they give you
know her father remember that she's
sweet but also heard her say she's gonna
leave her husband if he didn't get a job
she wanted didn't sound too sweet to me
yeah so i'm not buying the sweet crap
something else is going on here man i
don't like it at all i don't know what
just how you just mapped out the way you
handle challenges ups and downs puts you
in the top two percent of men i will
talk to all year that's incredible um so
there's something else going on here um
i don't i don't like dave i don't like
to get in the bluff calling game but i
would flip the lights on here and say
we're gonna go talk to a marriage
counselor today or tomorrow yeah uh
because there's there's something bigger
than just the financial sense security
here
yeah because you're making the money
right i interviewed yeah you know i am
and it's kind of funny that's where i'm
seeing
uh you know what right now i'm making
about
four thirty five thousand a year
about twenty six percent
and she knew i heard twenty six percent
i had a guy tell me it was up twenty six
percent that made a dollar too so twenty
percent don't do nothing unless there's
some money on the other end of that
formula 26 of zero still zero
but uh but you're making you know you're
making 38 000 and she's making what
she's making about 42 i make about 35
36.
and i'm seeing the competition crumble
around me you know the only other store
here the staples there's
uh it just went out of business there's
one guy in the uh the next town over
that does it it kind of does it as a
hobby and i'm starting to get clients
from him saying that they're unhappy
i don't ever want to knock somebody you
know this is not about you this is not
about your business my brother
yeah it's about your marriage
that's why i say this isn't going to be
solved with a calculator it's going to
be solved with the marriage counselor
yeah and this sucker's on life support
do you believe her she's threatening you
do you believe her
i don't know you know she's told me
before that she wasn't super happy here
and she was wondering if i was open to
moving to china and i guess at some
extent i was but
you know right now it's just not a plate
not a move i want to make you know i
don't have a degree
and uh you know i built this because i
didn't see any other options for work in
my field in the area uh you know
and uh
yeah that's exactly right brother i'm pr
it sounds like you're a hard worker you
stuck around longer than i would have
but it sounds like you're a grinder and
you're a hard worker and you sound like
a guy a character and you sound like a
guy who controls his emotions well and
it sounds like you're married to someone
who is looking for a way to get out
yeah and i hate to be the guy that's
breaking that to you in that way
man no no i you know i need to have
somebody
you know with some experience here just
tell me how it is you know really so
what you want to do in a situation where
we don't know we're we've been on the
radio with you for two minutes and so
it's a long yeah that's a fur piece from
us knowing everything about what's going
on over there but you have cultural
differences
that are pretty extreme
security uh
is a different thing when you come out
of a communist background
um and so and it has a different set of
uh emotions tied to it
but we've also got this uh
unhappiness this wanting to return to
china
um and maybe this is uh you know you
didn't do it so she had a felt like that
gave her the release i don't know that's
kind of what we're what we're
hypothesizing but the only way to find
out is to here's what you don't want to
do you don't want to just call the bluff
and then wonder what happened
you do want to
enter into this with some good
counseling
and so get on the phone and find a good
christian counselor in your area find a
good pastor in your area that can walk
you guys through this and sit down with
you and find out what the what is really
going on because this is not about you
taking a pay cut
for her to be happy
it's kind of ridiculous when you say it
out loud actually even if you're in
even if your income is volatile now if
she perceives because you don't bring
any money home you pull out it all back
into the business but if you had a
regular job you'd bring some money home
see that's not a pay cut in her mind
then that's a huge increase if you're
not bringing any money into the
household those types of things could
come out in a good counseling session
but i'm with john there's a lot going on
here that leads up to this this is not
sudden
this has been coming on it's been a slow
burn for a while and so you need to get
in what you don't want to have is regret
that you didn't try everything that's
right
so you try everything you flip the
lights on as john said you start
screaming you know fire fire fire and we
run out of the building because there's
a fire well turns out there's not a fire
but we at least we didn't die so we try
everything you go to the counselor and
do the best you can
and then when you get down to it she
still takes off and you still don't know
why um but at least you tried everything
yeah
and you don't have that regret of of
just kind of
being uh
laissez-faire about your marriage just
whatever you know quesara right now
instead we give it every shot we got you
leave it all on the field
and then if you lose you left it all in
the field but you don't want to play
half but and
and then
uh lose and then go well i'm not sure
why i lost except maybe my lack of
effort yeah is that what you're saying
yeah and that i just don't the phrase
calling somebody's bluff marriage is not
a game
it's something that you do together it's
not texas hold them you become one i'm
not i'm not calling anybody's bluff i'm
gonna figure out how
i can make this thing work on my end and
i'm gonna expect the same of you you
know with my spouse but if somebody's
down to throwing an ultimatum down a job
that is a fire alarm that there's all
kinds of crap going on inside your walls
even if you don't understand them
and you need to find out what that is